what advice would you give to a young
person today
about life about career we talked about
startups
we talked about music we talked about
the end of human civilization
is there advice you would give to a
young person today maybe in college
maybe in high school
about uh about their life well let's see
i mean there's so many domains you can
advise on
and you know i i'm not going to give
advice on life because i i fear that i
would drift into sort of hallmark
bromides
that really wouldn't be all that
distinctive and they might be entirely
true
sometimes the greatest insights about
life
turn out to be like the kinds of things
you'd see on a hallmark card so i'm
gonna steer clear that
on a career level you know one thing
that i think
um is unintuitive but unbelievably
powerful
is to focus not necessarily
in on being you know in the top sliver
of one percent
in excelling at one domain that's
important and valuable
but to think in terms of intersections
of two domains which are rare but
valuable
and there's a couple reasons for this
the first is in an incredibly
competitive world that is so much more
competitive than it was when i was
coming out of school
radically more competitive than when
when i was coming out of school
to navigate your way to the absolute
pinnacle of any domain let's say you
want to be
you know really really great at you know
python pick a language whatever it is
you want to be one of the world's
greatest
python developers javascript whatever
your language is hopefully it's not
cobalt
um but by the way if you listen to this
i am actually looking for a cobalt
expert to
interview because i find the language
fascinating and there's not many of them
so please
if you're if you know a world expert in
cobalt uh
or fortran but both actually or if you
are one or
if you are one please email me yeah so i
mean if you're going out there and you
want to be
in the top sliver one percent of python
develops is a very very difficult thing
to do particularly number one in the
world something like that
and i'll use an analogy is i had a
friend in college
um who was um on a track and indeed
succeeded at that to become an olympic
meddler
medalist and i think 100 meter
breaststroke and
he mortgaged a significant
percentage of his sort of college life
uh
to that goal i should say dedicated or
invested or whatever you wanted to say
but he didn't participate
in a lot of the social a lot of the late
night a lot of
this a lot of that because he was
training so much
and obviously he also wanted to keep up
with his academics and at the end of the
day
story has a happy ending and that he did
meddle in that
bronze not gold but holy cow anybody who
gets an olympic medal that's an
extraordinary thing and at that moment
he was you know one of the top three
people on earth at that thing
but wow how hard to do that how many
thousands
of other people went down that path and
made similar sacrifices and didn't get
there
it's very very hard to do that um
whereas you know they'll use a personal
example
um when i came out of business school i
went to a good business school and and
learn the things that were there to be
learned and i came out
and uh i entered a world with lots of
harvard business school by the way okay
yes it was harvard it's true
you're the first person who went there
who didn't say where you went it was
just beautiful i appreciate that
it's one of the greatest business
schools uh in the world
it's a it's a whole other fascinating
conversation about that world
but anyway but anyway so i learned the
things that you
you learn getting to be an mba from a
from a top program and i entered a world
that had hundreds of thousands of people
who had mbas
uh probably hundreds of thousands who
have them from you know top ten programs
uh but so i was not particularly great
at being an
mba person i was inexperienced uh
relative to most of them and there were
a lot of them but it was okay
mba person right newly minted uh
but then as it happened i found my way
into working on the commercial internet
in 1994
because i went to a at the time giant
hot computing company called silicon
graphics
which had enough heft and enough you
know head count that they could take on
and experience
mbas and try to train them in the world
of silicon valley
but within that comp that company that
had an enormous amount of surface area
and was touching very a lot of areas and
was
had unbelievably smart people at the
time uh
it was not surprising that sgi started
doing
really interesting and innovative and
trailblazing stuff on the internet
before almost anybody else
and part of the reason was that our
founder jim clark went off to co-found
netscape with mark andreessen so
the whole company was like wait what was
that what's this commercial internet
thing
so i end up in that group now in terms
of being a commercial internet person or
a world web
world wide web person um again uh
i was in that case barely credentialed i
couldn't write a stitch of code
but i got a had a pretty good mind for
grasping
the business and and and cultural uh
significance of this transition
and this was again we were talking
earlier about emerging areas
within a few months you know i was in
the relatively top echelon of people in
terms of just sheer experience
because like let's say it was five
months into the program there were only
so many people who had been doing
world wide web stuff commercially for
five months you know and then
what was interesting though was the
intersection of those two things
the commercial web as it turned out grew
into
an unbelievable vastness and so by being
a pretty good okay
web person and a pretty good okay mba
person
that intersection put me in a very rare
group which was
web oriented mbas and
in those early days you could probably
count on your fingers
the number of people who came out of
really competitive programs who were
doing stuff full-time
on the internet and and there was a
greater appetite
for great software developers in the
internet domain but there was an
appetite and a real one and a
rapidly growing one for mba
thinkers who were also seasoned and
networked
in the emerging world of the commercial
world wide web and so
finding an intersection of two things
you can be
pretty good at but is a rare
intersection
and a special intersection is probably a
much
easier way to make yourself
distinguishable and in demand from the
world
than trying to be world-class at this
one thing
so in the intersection is where there's
a to be discovered opportunity and
success
that's really interesting yeah there's
actually more intersection of fields and
fields themselves right so
yeah i mean i'll give you kind of a
funny hypothetical here but it's one
i've been thinking about a little bit
um there's a lot of people in crypto
right now it'd be hard to be
in the top percentile of crypto people
whether it comes from just having a
sheer grasp of the industry a great
network within the industry
technological skills whatever you want
to call it
um and then there's this parallel world
an orthogonal world
called crop insurance and there's you
know i'm sure that's a big world crop
insurance is a very very big
deal particularly in the wealthy and
industrialized world where people
through sophisticated financial markets
rule of law and
you know large agricultural concerns
that are worried about that
um somewhere out there is somebody who
is pretty crypto savvy but probably not
top one percent
but also has kind of been in the crop
insurance world and understands that a
hell of a lot better than almost anybody
who's ever had anything to do with
cryptocurrency
and so i think that um decentralized
finance defy
one of the interesting and i think very
world positive things that i think it's
almost inevitably will be bringing to
the world
is crop insurance for small holding
farmers
you know i mean people who have tiny
tiny plots of land
in places like india etc where there is
no crop insurance available to them
because
just the financial infrastructure
doesn't exist
but it's highly imaginable that using
oracle networks
that are trusted outside deliverers of
factual information about rainfall in a
particular area you can start giving
drought insurance to folks like this
the right person to come up with that
idea is not a crypto whiz
who doesn't know a blasted thing about
small holding farmers the right person
to come up with that is not a crop
insurance whiz
who isn't quite sure what bitcoin is but
somebody occupies that intersection
that's just one of gazillion examples of
things that are going to come along for
somebody who
occupies the the right intersection of
skills but isn't necessarily
the number one person at either one of
those expertises
that's making me kind of wonder about my
own little
things that i'm average at and seeing
were
the intersections that could be
exploited
that's pretty profound
you